Peggy's 16
welcome to more home city of the Damned
a tactical RPG adapted from the famous
tabletop game from Games Workshop left
in ruins after a twin-tailed comet
struck the city a rare resource called
worth stone has been scattered
throughout the city of mordheim jump
into turn-based lethal skirmishes with
one of the four playable war bands the
human mercenaries thus kavanaugh
clannish in the sisters of sigmar and
the culturally possessed by the glory
golden order or simply for the thrill of
spreading chaos and destruction more
times single-player campaign features a
story for each of the four war banks as
you progress through the story you'll
impose your will over your rivals
securing the precious words they
overpower enemies with a group of
heavily armed soldiers Master trickery
and deceit with assassins or use magic
to blow away any opposition the choice
is yours ambush or foes provide
overwatch for your allies scale walls
and jump between crevices do anything it
takes to survive in conquer when the
dust settles for a moment take some time
to explore the cursed city with valuable
items and find lost treasures higher
level up and customized units with a
plethora of skills gear and squad
configurations suitable field chosen
approach as your warband becomes more
experienced give units oil bombs to
throw powerful spells to cast and
multitude of abilities to expand your
strategic options but be warned a bad
call could risk losing the upper hand in
battle a permanent injury or worse death
once confident in your warband take your
troops online to challenge other players
tweak every aspect of your multiplayer
experience with a whole slew of maps
procedurally generated backgrounds with
exciting deployment possibilities or
active maps specific gameplay mode
fight for glory and word stone in
mordheim city of the Damned but beware
danger and better lurks in every corner
you